yes thank you so much for coming to
speak to us today we've read a lot of
different views in our class about the
role and the ability of the free market
to address problems of social inequality
and help these marginalized populations
that you've been speaking about we've
read views about this idea of
philanthropy ilysm where there's this
idea that people who have made it in
business have a hyper agency and they
had their able to give in a way and
invest with a lot of impact and then on
the left side we have read you know
criticisms of corporate social
responsibility saying that companies
that are for-profit inherently cannot
cannot address these issues of social
inequality because they're responsible
to the Board of Governors to their
shareholders to the investors so how
would you address that critique and
where do you think impact your idea of
impact investing falls in this spectrum
I think the reality is I think that I
think the key word that you just use
this spectrum right I think the reality
is it is a very broad spectrum and there
will be some businesses where a more
distinct and perhaps difficult choice
has to be made between the impact and
the profit motives and some not let me
give an example to your to the second
half of your of your question I'm on the
board of a company called clean engines
incorporated that company is looking to
retrofit tuk-tuks I don't know if you
all know what took talks are but are the
three wheelers that that you find in
many many Asian cities there are an
estimated one or two hundred million
around around Asia one took took is
responsible for the equivalent of 50
cars worth of emissions toxicity in
Asian cities like Manila and Bangkok is
actually starting to kill what this
company is doing is retrofitting took
talks with clean engines using LPG or
compressed natural gas the moment that
vehicle has been retrofitted not only
does the drivers income double but the
efficiency goes through the roof the
toxicity over time obviously falls in in
the in the in the city because they're
these took trucks are no longer pumping
out the emissions right there is
absolutely no
season and I don't think from my
perspective any of us should have a
problem with the fact that this
hopefully one day will be a
multi-billion dollar company we could
also significantly significantly impact
pollution rates and health amongst the
poorest of the poor urban dwellers
tuk-tuk drivers in a range of countries
that to me is it is a pure impact
investment win-win where you've got a
sort of uber profit motive if you will
and a lot of money eventually being made
with an extraordinary private sector
resolution to a problem which certainly
the public sector in the government
hasn't touched or being able to do
anything about but having said that not
every business has such a perfect
symbiosis if you will between the social
and the and the and the profit side or
the financial side so your point is also
well taken that's what makes it so
complicated